[Musique]
bon maintenant faut le tenir comment ce
masque pour avoir l'IR
crédible sous le bras comme ça c'est
bien ou s comme ça c'est bien va falloir
tout reprendre depuis le début commence
c'est quoi les bases quand on commence à
faire de l'esrim déjà il y a trois armes
c'est ça le la première étape c'est
chois entre les TR est-ce que tu connais
les trois il y a le fleuret le sabre et
l'épé bien joué l'épé on touche qu'avec
la pointe la tête au pied si les deux
touch les de en point c'est de lefelle
le sa tu touches tout ce que de la
ceinture c'est pour ça que moi je suis
tout en grise mais juste auudessus parce
qu'avant on était les cavaliers donc
fallait pas toucher le cheval mais par
contre nous on touche pas qu'avec la
poince on peut trancher l'adversaire un
petit côté B un petit côté bourin ça va
du coup beaucoup plus vite et Le Fur
c'est un mix des deux c'est un peu comme
l'épée on touche aussi qu' avec la
pointe et c'est le bu les épauler le
dos du coup pour prendre le sabre tu
mets le pouce là et tu
sers pas trop fort c'est quand même du
doigt t même si c'est une arme de
barbare et après tu un peu de finesse et
après tu peux me toucher comme ça comme
ça ou si tu veux me trancher comme ça OK
et on apprend quoi en premier du coup on
escrime on commence par quelle base
d'abord je vais t'apprendre à te mettre
en garde comme ça tu vas apprendre à te
déplacer tu es droitier donc tu mets le
pied avant vers moi hop la main comme ça
tu fléchis un peu et voilà là tu es en
regarde et là la marche ou la retraite
c'est comme ça
ok le talon du pied avant talon du pied
avant et tu pousses voilà OK et la
retraite c'est pareil tu pousses hop tu
reviens VO
marche ramène bien t pied arrière hop
voilà de pierres de retraite et pour
toucher la et voilà c'est bon tu es prêt
on y va on prend les armes et on y va
les armes tu me défies tu es sûr de toi
les G c'est dans
un ok très bien c'est
parti
[Musique]
et ben honnêtement je m'attendais à pire
niveau confort on voit presque bien
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parti l'agression quoi
ouais ça c'est une
[Musique]
parade pour Rigo
fait
[Musique]
mal ten c'est la tenue pour ça marque
pas des
POS VO là c'est bon tu vois moi je t'
attaqué moi j'ai fait une contreattaque
donc c'est toi qui
[Musique]
FO rien oh là là écoute maintenant merci
beaucoup pour ce petit cour Express tu
très sympa trè bonne découverte
qu'est-ce qu'on peut te souhaiter là
qu'est-ce qu'on peut te souhaiter je
pense que tuas une petite idée ouais
mais je voulais pas aller direct sur
cette é 2024 il a étapes une petite
médaille d'or c'est cool on prend tout
ce qu'on peut prendre et bencoute on te
le souhaite on te suivra et puis merci
encore pour cette matinée merci à toi à
bientôt et on se la fin match